[Musique]
le tueur tequila ganeti a chakram une
odeur sanglante techniquement Milton s'il vous plaît faites
attention, je dégage
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
maintenant que les vies noires comptent a enfin
fait sa marque et que les vies noires
comptent beaucoup  plus de changement systémique,
alors ces entreprises veulent venir
et faire le plus petit ajustement
possible pour s'adapter
au nouveau type de politiquement correct
et ce n'est pas assez bon, elles devraient
faire beaucoup plus pour réparer
le tort du père qu'elles  ont
fait parce qu'ils vendaient essentiellement
des produits de pêche qui nuisaient à la
peau et qu'ils nuisaient également profondément
à la psyché des gens qui grandissaient,
en particulier les jeunes femmes qui grandissaient, les filles qui
grandissaient et ainsi de suite parce
qu'elles mettaient beaucoup d'argent dans
normalisant cette idée que vous êtes
moins que si vous étiez
dans l'industrie cinématographique lorsque nous choisissons
les gens en termes de rôles, c'est si clair
que vous savez que si vous devez jouer un
rôle instruit en milieu urbain, ce serait une
personne à la peau claire et si vous jouez un
villageois et une personne pauvre, cela doit être
fait, je suppose que la première étape consiste
à reconnaître qu'il y a quelque chose qui
ne va pas et c'est ce qui se passe et
je pense que la vie des Noirs compte a
définitivement donné une sorte de coup de pouce
parce que c'est en quelque sorte un plus grand
débat et discours beaucoup plus larges
[Musique]